breaking tonight what was supposed to be
a Labor Day adventure has turned into a
deadly nightmare for people on a
chartered diving boat off the coast of
California at least four are dead and 29
more are missing after a devastating
early morning fire corresponding
Christina Coleman is live in Los Angeles
tonight good evening Christina
good evening Mike well a frantic search
is underway for more than two dozen
people after this diving ship burst into
flames early this morning forcing the
ship's crew members to jump overboard
four bodies have been recovered so far
the Coast Guard saying their injuries
were consistent with drowning take a
listen to the dispatcher on the Mayday
call when the deadly fire was reported
you can't hear how the crew member is
responding but it sure gives you a sense
of the situation
[Applause]
Coast Guard harbor patrol officers
helicopters all rushed to the scene once
the call came in around 3:30 this
morning 39 people were aboard the diving
ship Concepcion including five crew
members who all made it off the 75 foot
boat near Santa Cruz Island a Coast
Guard officer says people were below
deck asleep
however those five crew members were
awake and above deck and able to jump
off the ship
two of them suffering minor injuries a
Good Samaritan let them onto their boat
to get them to safety the Concepcion st.
just 20 yards offshore in 64 feet of
water while firefighters were trying to
put out that fire we managed to get
video of a rescued man brought ashore
alert and talking to first responders
the dive boat was on the last day of a
Labor Day weekend cruise to the Channel
Islands about 70 miles north of Los
Angeles loved ones gathered at the
harbor in Santa Barbara where the
conception was based hoping for good
news this man just found out his brother
a cook on the boat had escaped usually
he's making breakfast at 4:00 in the
morning
so something happened he got off of the
boat seized one of the survivors so I'm
going in here to talk to him right now
California Senator Dianne Feinstein once
answer she released a statement just
moments ago saying the FBI and NTSB will
be investigating the Coast Guard says an
early look at the boats records show it
is in compliance with state laws and
that the owner of the boat is
cooperating with investigators Mike
Christina Coleman live in LA Christina
thanks a lot